neuvième génération qui est vu toi quant
au nabot cf carré je suis une amie j'ai
été extraites de météo l'afrique a
appelé le ghana désarroi d'arômes et des
figures marquantes de notre histoire qui
s'interpellent comme un écho du passé
venant questionner le visiteur dans les
ruines de dubuc ancienne exploitation
sucrière d'entrée de jeu le ton est
donné
le festival martinique merveilles du
monde veut marier ludique et pédagogique
vers le haut de gamme
il y a de toutes les façons l'enfant en
chacun d'entre nous et cet enfant a
besoin d'émerveillement et a besoin de
découvrir de manière magique son
histoire l'histoire de six ans est et
probablement de ceux projetés et pour
cela je crois que le public quel qu'il
soit est en écoute en attente et en
partage pour le lancement de son
festival pnrm n'a pas lésiné sur les
activités sports nautiques et skill
games randonnée ou atelier photo il faut
dire que le site atypique de la
caravelle s'y prête parfaitement
on a prévu de faire du poney également
l'atelier peinture c'est super bien ça
m'apprend des choses sur la nature sur
les photos c'est magnifique que l'on
connaissait pas donc
on est de fort de france ne connaissait
pas le château c'est superbe
l'histoire n'est pas à véhiculer à
l'école donc ce serait bien que liège
beaucoup d'enfants qu'ils soient là pour
connaître un peu notre histoire
alors que cette année les vacances au
pays devrait être plébiscité une
vingtaine de manifestations vont ainsi
rythmer le mois de juillet prochain
rendez vous le mardi 7 pour une
découverte des richesses de la mangrove
de génie parc